l'espace à la science fiction il n'y a
qu'un pas les auteurs l'ont d'ailleurs
franchi depuis bien longtemps les
cinéastes aussi à tel point que depuis
quelques années un festival du film
fantastique et de science-fiction se
déroule à paris la première année 5000
personnes seulement avaient fait le
déplacement
l'an passé soixante mille spectateurs
ont suivi les projections ce festival se
tient en ce moment même et il se
terminera à paris le 21 mars
c'est ce cri qu'ils sont venus entendre
le loubard venu en moto2 la bastille le
visiteur assidu des librairies de
saint-germain-des-prés se sont retrouvés
pour dix jours festival du fantastique
façon d astronef aux fantômes del est
venu de la planète mars aux vampires ils
sont venus 50 milles entre deux tours
d'élections changé en somme de planète
qu'est ce qui vous attire ici en plaçant
ce sont les pauvres
si vous aimez le plus dans les coûts
vente
me sens comme onirique
allez y avec sommes capables de donner
l'appréhension d'un nouveau réel l'ariel
à conquérir acquérir voulez pas deux il
effectivement valable alors on s'est
adapté à son prix complètement rasé
j'adore l'espace et le film de récents
sondages contesté débat que la femme se
l'avenir de l'humanité comme la science
fiction à tout ce qui doit arriver je
pense qu'elle doit être très bien ces
jeunes et anciens
j'aime bien par part et pourquoi j'ai
bien peur que j'ai l'impression parfois
aussi que peut-être se défoulent des
pulsions un peu sadique sur scène blues
lavinal dernière qui était
particulièrement aux rides et moi j'ai
trouvé ça très bien alors que c'est une
personne très bien donc ça fait les
villes si on a peur c'est normal
ils vont à oui j'aime bien le trois
quarts centre d'affairé fantastique
classique pas tellement la science
fiction je tiens vraiment à cesser les
pandores donc pas spécialement les
femmes eurent leur heure
au moins les prochains mois pourquoi ben
j'y crois pas mes journées fort qu'elle
est partie grâce aux avait peur
riez c'est pour dire ouvrir pour les
rejouer des scènes qui sont volés 5 qui
sont marrants du jour mais aussi quand
c'est vraiment comique où j'aime bien
les vendre le bal des vampires
j'aime bien voir les vampires n'ont pas
parce qu'ils sont effrayants et parce
qu'on n'en voit pas tous les jours
c'est une porte ouverte en définitif sur
tout et c'est ce qui est un véhicule
très intéressant pour exprimer beaucoup
de beaucoup de choses aussi bien des
fantasmes désir d'ordre politiques ou
sociaux on sait pas si demain on va pas
y avoir la fin du monde c'est jamais
pensé que je croyais la fin du monde à
moi j'y crois moi personnellement je
suis un peu superstitieux alors j'y
crois c'est un besoin du coeur et et de
l'imagination de coeur parce que les les
romans de science-fiction des histoires
de science fiction si bien que les
histoires de deux fantastiques remettre
en cause
l'être humain